hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on for tonight again in
today's video we're gonna be talking
about new emo concepts that fans from
the community have made now these are
only concepts and they are not
officially in the game at this current
time so if you're looking for actual new
emotes coming then you're sadly mistaken
I apologize but it was in the title that
it is concepts these are only stuff made
from the community other than that let's
get started
I will leave links to each of the
rheticus and links to the creators that
put them in because always nice to
credit the artist since most of these
don't have videos I will try to show
what they look like there's similar
pictures to help you out so now to get
started the first emo is a video showing
a created emo called the crank by
Schmeck enger on reddit this video shows
the character winding up his hand to
show a middle finger as if it's like a
jack-in-the-box type crank this has to
be my personal favorite out of the list
since the person took the time to
actually make the animation even though
I have absolutely no one like no clue at
all how this was made and it could
create so much salt for your opponent
when you use them my only issue with
this though is that when the person dies
that obviously spectate you and they
won't be able to see the emote because
it's in front of you and your back is
blocking it but it is very funny
nonetheless someone in the comments
suggested that you can use this on it a
person who is down to definitely tilt
that player that would be a lot better
than to use it on a person who is
already dead spectating you well like I
said this is a really funny emo and
congrats on making it pro is really
funny the next one up is one-man band by
otter Wolfie on reddit and the whole
gist of this emo is your person is
basically playing music like he's the
only one in a band meaning he plays the
guitar the drums and any other
instrument included for that specific
song I think would be nice especially if
you can get tons of people together to
form your own band the devs could also
split this up and have a separate guitar
and drum emote so each person can have
the preferred instrument and as well
that they can have a different type of
song play every time or something like
that to kind of spice up the emo instead
of having the same old boring song every
single time the next emo is actually
three emotes and they are there to
person required emotes by lime plays on
reddit and according to the description
it reads just an idea I thought of
yesterday made a concept for visually
understanding the idea is pretty
straightforward one person with either
approach or be approached it must be a
teammate or in the waiting lobby and
when one person clicks too
from the emo any players and a certain
radius will have the option to join in
on the emo only the first person will be
choosen now these three emotes are
rock-paper-scissors high-five and the
get carried mo the get carried one is
nice since that sometimes you just have
to carry your teammates to victory when
they're slacking or just going off and
going off what the image says what it
looks like it looks really cool kind of
like you're flying in your buddies on
your shoulders kind of thing it looks
really nice I definitely do like the
visual understanding of it the
rock-paper-scissors one which is
probably my favorite out of the three
cuz you could either have it so each
time that it's random or have players
picked them by themselves to maybe
increase the competition on this you
could although you could also do this to
see who gets to loot in a situation
numerous times my friends would argue
who gets the gold scar who gets the RPG
depending on who kill them or not
whether that be from a Supply Drop
chests dead opponent whatever it happens
to be now you can settle those
differences and do a best out of two or
three or rock-paper-scissors or do none
of that and just steal the loot for
yourself doesn't really matter and then
lastly the high five is pretty
self-explanatory you win a match the
drew teammate save your life or you just
want to show a friendly gesture give
your buddy a high five these are really
well done so thanks to the lime place
for that on reddit really a nice work
ruffle before it's emote today is going
to be a selfie emo buy mixed Terry AK on
reddit I'm so sorry if I butchered that
name that's probably very as really hard
for me to get and it's very simple
though your character will take a selfie
and according to the bottom it says that
he it will be saved as a screenshot when
you take it you can use this in many
ways like if you if your team just one
you want to thank group photo or maybe
show off the base you just built or the
fact that you clear a tile all have
tilted towers and somehow managed to not
die the possibilities for this are
absolutely endless this emo though was
actually looked at by one of the
developers on fortnight and they sent
two suggestions the people higher up at
epic studios to maybe get put into the
game which is super nice this I believe
this reddit post was made about a week
ago so maybe this could be implemented
later in the game I'd really like to see
this because this is a really nice
suggestion not a lot of gaming companies
do this though when I listen to the
community so I'm glad that they're doing
this a lot more and then the last emote
today is going to be a Dragon Ball
fusion emo my end cats on reddit it also
shows his Twitter in the bottom right
which I'll leave which is neglected
kitty and I also found out that he has a
YouTube channel called
Eva which I'll link as well for you guys
to check out morphus stuff because this
was really a really nice suggestion but
basically if you don't know this is a
reference to the Dragon Ball episode
we're go ten and Trunks fusing to go
tanks I'm assuming there is more than
one time two people fused in a Dragon
Ball episode I'm not a big fan on Dragon
Ball but this is the most notable
transformation of course everybody
usually knows that when you think a
Dragon Ball so that's probably what this
specific one was based off of the emote
though would be the little dance they do
to perform the fusion but probably and
probably follow the same procedure as
the last emote we talked about with the
- with the two-person emote since it
does require two people in order to
start it this is a very nice idea and I
would assume it was implemented
obviously you can't fuse into one
character that might be a little bit
game breaking and I don't know how
they'd be able to do that so your
characters would probably do a little
dance and that's about it maybe it will
loop maybe it won't but either way this
is really cool it is also a very unique
idea once again shout out to n cats for
that I reddit this is also a very nice
idea as well as the other four of course
let me know what you guys think was your
favorite in the comments below I love to
know and if you have your own type of
idea for an emo and Ford and I also let
me know in the comments below I'd love
to hear your types of creations for this
like I said all emo shown will have
links in the description as well as
their Twitter and YouTube pages if it
was displayed on the reddit post all
that type of [ __ ] is gonna be in the
description below because I always like
to credit the people I like the good
stuff from because they deserve it
but either way that's going to be the
end of the video today guys like the
video if you guys did enjoy really just
help me out I tried to do something a
little bit different before and I hope
you guys like that
other people have done like storm ideas
and other types of skins that I might
cover in the future as well you guys
want to see more that day a lot of
people have some really nice-looking
ideas and I'd love to show them off to
the community with credited of course I
always want to credit the artists
subscribe if you're new I cover a lot of
Fortnight content that being guides tips
to make people better players I got more
coming either today or by the end of
tomorrow or Thursday I don't know what
day it will be but I have a video idea
coming very soon my two most recent
videos are going to be on screen if you
guys do want to check that out and with
that guys hope you have a great Easter
day and peace out